this was chad's president idris debbie
campaigning last week
provisional election results indicated
he'd won a sixth term in office
but debbie had reportedly joined his son
and other soldiers on saturday
to repel an attack by a rebel group in
the northern province of canim near the
border with libya
according to the military he was
severely injured
it says it will now create a
transitional military council led by
debbie's son
and has suspended the constitution
a transitional government will be put in
place new republican institutions will
be put in place to facilitate the
transition by the organization of free
democratic and transparent elections
following the spirit of sacrifice
that the marshal of chatter fought for
all his life right up until his last
suffering
idris debbie was a former military
officer who came to power in 1990
he'd faced numerous coup attempts and
analysts say he had a reputation for
ruthlessness
the electoral campaign was very violent
and just uh i think
some people will in this moment remember
that
idris davies troops and police
surrounded the home of an opponent and
killed his mother
the rebel front for change and concord
group wanted to remove
debbie as president it attacked a
government position at the border on
election day on april the 11th
chad's closest ally france provided its
military with logistical support and
intelligence
it seems like the the removal of debbie
has not changed the military situation
and as long as the military remains
largely loyal to his son which seems
likely to be the case given that he used
to be the commander
of the presidential guard and the
chattanooga's best units
um he's a four-star general he's only 37
years old
if he can keep that loyalty then there's
no way the rebellion can can
take advantage of that any more than
they could have under his father
more than 300 rebel fighters have
reportedly been killed in the fighting
over the past few days
the president debbie has now also died
in the fighting has shocked a nation
and made the security situation in the
wider sahel region
even more fragile victoria gatenbee al
jazeera
now heber morgan is following
developments from chad's capital and
jamina and says the army was quick to
implement a military council
so soon after debbie's death the first
thing that the military announced
following
uh the announcement that address debbie
has passed away from his injuries
is that they are suspending the
constitution as well as dissolving the
government
and the legislative assembly or the
parliament so all those institutions
that were in place
uh prior to the death of president idris
debbie are no longer in place and now we
have his son
37 year old mohammed idris who is a
four-star general
and who was the second in command in the
charging intervention
force in northern mali so he does have a
certain degree of uh military experience
which is uh which looks like what this
military or the transitional military
council is looking
uh to lead this country during this um
crisis that is uh
formed due to the death of president
debbie now we've also
uh looked at the members of the
transitional military council themselves
11 members
most of them from the army uh from
various ethnicities and tribes
that is something it looks like the army
has studied very well there has been
concerns
that there will be division in in chad
especially amongst the military in a
country
where security has always been top
priority that is something we heard
uh repeatedly from people here during
elections saying that they're concerned
about the security
so it looks like the army started this
very well during the period where debbie
was
suffering from his injuries and made
sure to come up with the transition
military council
emma idris is in abuja in neighboring
nigeria and says debbie's staunch
support for military action against
rebel troops will be missed by regional
leaders
he's no stranger to leading his troops
on the battlefront last year
he was on the shows of lecture leading
the champion troops
and that helped in ousting boko haram or
routing them from charging territories
and then he made an announcement a
controversial announcement that recently
was
later was later clarified by the charity
authorities he said well
he has dealt with the problem on his
territory it's up to the
neighboring countries to deal with the
problems what he doesn't want to see
is that them relaxing their guards and
then
the boko haram fighters and iso fighters
streaming back into child again later on
he met with the regional leaders and
they discussed
and there were some progress to a
certain extent and we've seen
an uptick in the movement of charging
forces in the region which
of course helped to deal with the
problems now the conflict is raging
we've seen how boko haram has succeeded
in attacking military formations
occupying briefly some towns and cities
in the northeast of the country
and cameroon is also dealing with its
own problems now these countries will
definitely miss
idris derby's uh contributions
in in this region and not not only in
the lecture region we're talking about
the sahel
burkina faso mali uh countries like
france which also relied on the
expertise
and the experience of china forces in
dealing with crisis in the region
these countries will definitely miss
that experience